I went to my first a a meeting when I
was 7 years old and I know what you guys
are thinking what the hell within this
girl's baby bottle spoiler alert I was
not an alcoholic at age 7 my uncle took
me to that AAA meeting because there
were people in my family who were in
fact there are people in my family
suffering from many forms of addiction
knowing that addiction would
dramatically affect my life he wanted me
to be informed about it so he exposed me
to addiction from the viewpoint of an
addict so that I could understand their
struggle according to the center of
addiction 40 million Americans are
suffering from substance addiction this
includes alcohol illicit drugs and
prescription opioids 40 million that's
nearly one in every eight people look at
your row on average at least one person
is addicted 138 million Americans have a
close friend or family member who is
suffering from addiction this nearly 50%
of our entire country who knows an
addict and yet due to shame people that
know an addict never talk about it
they hide it from their friends they
hide it from their neighbors they even
hide it from other family members people
who know an addict go through great
lights to keep this secret
I know because up until this talk I was
one of these people drug addiction is
defined by the National Institute for
drug abuse as a complex chronic brain
disease characterized by drug craving
seeking and youth the key to this
craving is dopamine dopamine is a
neurotransmitter in your brain that's
responsible for pleasure totally natural
and necessary
in dopamine surges happen when you're
watching a movie you really love or
eating foods that you enjoy perhaps
chocolate or pasta or when you're having
sex well hopefully when you consume a
drug over time it's over stimulates the
dopamine in your system causing a
euphoric effect that is 2 to 10 times
the amount that your body is used to
this is the high but over time when you
continue to consume drugs it the surges
in dopamine really make it difficult to
participate in life fully this is why
when addicts aren't using drugs they
complain of feeling flat lifeless and
depressed all the time at this point it
stops being about using drugs to get
high and starts being about using drugs
just to feel normal just to feel
something an addict needs substances to
reach the same levels of dopamine as a
non drug user
it literally addiction literally rewires
your brain addiction is not a choice
this is literally a brain disease so the
question then becomes if research has
proven that addiction is not a choice
but a brain disease how in the United
States do we justify putting addicts and
treatment in prisons instead of
treatment centers I mean would we put
cancer patients in prison because they
have cancer of course not 65% of prison
inmates are clinically addicted many of
them were convicted for personal drug
use not even intent to sell
we put addicts in prison for the
compulsive use of a drug that their
brain literally tells them that they
need to survive but this is not just
about an increase in the
and population addiction cost our
economy a lot of money five hundred and
twenty billion dollars to be exact this
is the cost to our economy and lost work
productivity health care expenses
criminal justice costs and law
enforcement costs and the problem is
only growing opioid addiction alone has
grown by four hundred and ninety three
percent in the last seven years the US
Surgeon General has declared opioid
addiction a public health crisis that is
both underappreciated and undertreated
do addicts choose to try these
substances yes
were they coerced into trying them
probably not but does that mean that
they choose an entire life of addiction
no no one grows up and says I really
really want to be an addict when I get
older they just don't I spoken to you
guys today about a number of statistics
but addiction is not statistics
addiction is the mother who lies to her
family and friends because she is too
ashamed to admit that her son has a drug
problem addiction is the father who
steals from his kids piggy banks to feed
his drug habit
addiction is being called by the police
to identify your sister's body because
she just overdosed these are not
examples that I made up these are
examples from people that I know some of
whom are in this room right now my uncle
took me to that a a meeting when I was
seven because he knew what I did not
know my mother was addicted to crack
like many AD
she was unreliable she was irresponsible
and when I was four she stopped caring
for me altogether growing up as the
child of an addict is a very painful and
traumatic experience you live in secrecy
mortified that people will judge you for
this disease so you do everything you
can to keep it hidden when I was little
I used to just think if I could just get
more straight A's or more Awards she
would want to be my mom again I didn't
understand how my mom could have won a
drug more than she wanted me
I recently remit my mom after 23 years
people asked me how do you forgive an
addict how do you forgive addiction
understanding that this is not a choice
but literally a brain disease is a
critical step I wasn't sure how to give
this talk today because the topic is so
taboo and so personal but there are
literally 40 million Americans that are
suffering from this disease and if we do
not start treating this like the health
issue that it really is we are further
enabling the disease that is killing
thousands destroying families all over
this country and has a real economic
cost we as a society have to make a
paradigm shift into how we are
addressing addiction one that creates
more patients and fewer prisoners thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]